I don't know if you remember what the article was about,
but I wrote about,
uh,
Eric Green Murray is a professor at the political science department and he was
forced to include,
uh,
Judith Butler,
Butler.
Oh yeah,
right.
Chewed his butler.
Yeah.
Great,
great.
And,
uh,
the course is about modern society and its and its critics.
So it's been amazing basically about the reactionary forces and a left wing
extremist forces during the turn of the last century.
So in the early 20th century,
late 19th century.
And then you read Butler,
um,
and actually one of the course a and not Eric,
but,
uh,
his,
his teaching assistant interview
and she said that she disagreed with the method.
So she agreed with the professors that she did.
She thought that the academic freedom was more important than,
uh,
being forced to teach about a feminist authors,
certain gender science.
So she was actually,
uh,
on the other side.
Gender Science.
Yeah,
exactly.
Where is by no means a scientist or even a credible academic?
As far as I'm concerned,
I think she's a straight out idealog and um,
and the fact that anybody would be forced,
well first of all forced to include anything on their curriculum I think is
absolutely reprehensible.
It's top down interference with academic freedom and it's extraordinarily
dangerous because once that
precedent is established,
then you opened the door for political interference in the like,
I like,
like organized political interference from outside the academy and it'll
collapse very rapidly underserved.
We saw that happening in Germany and also in the Soviet Union and like that can
happen so quickly that people can't,
can't,
it's almost impossible to believe.
Now we're in this weird situation where the same thing seems to be happening to
a large degree within the academy itself.
And so,
and what to do about that is by no means obvious but,
but I don't think that allowing external control of any sort over the contents
of the courses the professor teach professors teach is,
it's a very,
very bad idea.
We,
uh,
they have a rule,
rule of thumb,
they call it,
but it's basically,
it's much more a rule,
the rule of thumb.
But at least 40% of all the literature has to be written by women.
So if you are unbelievable,
if you're holding a course,
for example,
about Portland Society,
then it's critic critics with a lot of primary literature from the turn of the
century,
then you run into a problem because women weren't,
uh,
so,
there weren't a lot of women were authors back then.
You,
oh,
he's so unbelievably,
yeah.
I would say resentful.
I really think that's the fundamental issue here,
to push a doctor resentful and uninformed to push a doctrine like that.
Yeah.